y ahora
[Música]
se imaginan ustedes una empresa en la
cual los empleados eligen al gerente
general una empresa en la cual se
elimina los controles
una empresa en la cual los mismos
empleados organizan sus horarios de
trabajo una misma empresa en la cual las
remuneraciones y los números son
transparentes una misma empresa en la
cual el propósito de ella misma es
construido por todos
todo comienza en el año 97 cuando con mi
familia decidimos cambiar de país de
francia y venir a perú porque finalmente
queríamos volver a nacer
queríamos aprender otro idioma queríamos
aprender nuestra cultura queríamos
ofrecer a nuestros hijos otra mirada
sobre el mundo y también hacer un
negocio que nunca habíamos hecho
así tanto así que finalmente el 97
llegamos a lima y en 98 abrimos nuestro
primer negocio abrimos la cadena de
lavanderías presto y todo va bien 98 99
2000 2001 2002 2003 y 2003 todos a
youtube
intento de secuestro de mis dos hijas
salín 10 años 6 y 8 años
en estos momentos les conservamos por la
seguridad a mi familia les confirmamos
del sistema
todos estos que estamos a francia y
desde francia y otra etapa de delegar lo
que podría delegar éramos más o menos 60
empleados
yo era el gerente general el dueño
fundador tratando de ligar lo que se
podía tener reportes controlar
no recibía la responsabilidad que yo
esperaba de mis empleados
tampoco yo no confiaba tan no confiaba
tanto y esto duró tres años duró tres
años porque en donde en 2007 volvemos a
perú porque la empresa era un desastre
éramos estábamos al borde de la quiebra
entonces de a poco la equilibramos
evitamos que se que haya más
y poco a poco y bien
14 nuevo golpe 2014
está bien a mi hermano me llamo desde
francia me dice ahora que tienes que
regresar a francia sí
pero porque nuestro padre está muy
enfermo y te necesitamos
ya claro no hay problema yo vuelvo tome
el pueblo y primero no hay problemas sí
pero hay un detalle
dime
te recomiendo no comprar tu boleto de
regreso a perú
porque no sabemos
qué podría pasar
en este momento me sentí científico muy
reactivo cayendo cayendo y cayendo y
cayendo
y cayendo por dos motivos el primero por
mi padre
y el segundo por qué
vivía otra vez el año 2003 con este
intento de secuestro donde tuve que
alejarme de mi empresa
como hago
mi padre de un lado mi empresa que puedo
que puede desaparecer que hago habrá
otra forma otra forma de manejar el
negocio
algo
en mí no se había cumplido en mi vida de
empresario desde que tengo 21 años algo
no había logrado hacer una empresa en la
cual se puede confiar en todos eso era
un sueño pero nunca lo logré además en
un país en el cual según las
encuestadoras el 90% de las personas no
confían en otra persona que hago
de sido sigue a mi intuición me acercó a
mí a mis responsables de la época eran
cinco los responsables eran jefes en
esta época y os pregunto chicos tengo
que irme a francia porque mi padre está
enfermo y me gustaría saber cómo se van
a organizar ustedes
la respuesta de ellos ha sido
este mismo silencio
chicos si a mí me pasaría algo como es
organizarían ustedes
y la respuesta
el mismo silencio
chicos acá estaré pisará están los
plumones
les dejo cinco minutos juntos ustedes 5
y mientras tanto ustedes van a diseñar
cómo se organizan y salgo del oficina
salgo de la oficina y me sentía como
paracaidista que salta del avión y no
puedo volver a subir
cinco mil dos larguísimas vuelvo en la
oficina y que veo
veo esto
alicia de vida omar cesar y hugo habían
diseñado este organigrama con este
permite
sentí tres cosas la primera cosa me
sentía contento porque habían diseñado
algo
y es más se habían ubicado los cuatro
donde yo no hubiera hecho según sus
habilidades sus gustos perfecto pero hay
dos cosas que me golpearon fuerte mi ego
ha sido golpeado
la primera cosa y como ustedes pueden
verlo arriba no está es que tu origen
soy un yo no estoy es hugo hugo verás
que es uno de los cinco
estaba bien estaba mal
no sabía qué pensar hasta ahora
pero creo que lo que más me golpeó
es que
ni mi nombre ni me pilló ni mis
iniciales no figuran adentro de este
organigrama ni fuera y en ningún lugar
de la pizarra nada yo desaparezco
totalmente
se puede imaginar cuando uno tiene a
empresas desde sus 21 años llega casi a
sus 50 y desaparece en el mapa
en este momento no sabía que decíamos ok
chicos bien
ok
ya
ya pasamos al segundo tema de la reunión
y veremos eso más tarde
la reunión termina lo primero que hago
voy en google
ya que busco la empresa
con confianza la empresa autogestionada
controla 10 mil kilómetros no sabía qué
buscar y finalmente encuentra una web en
el cual veo que existen empresas en
francia en europa en todos los
continentes en todos los rubros todos
los sectores desde pequeñas hasta cien
hasta miles de ampliados y sin jefes
nunca había escuchado eso
entonces me interesó durante toda la
semana hasta la segunda reunión que era
la semana siguiente
me acerco chicos la reunión comienza de
una manera un poco alejada y muy chicos
de lo que mostrará de la semana pasada
del organigrama como cómo se sienten sí
señor estamos listos
no solamente yo me había preocupado
porque algo con esa situación pero ellos
se habían proyectado realmente en esta
posibilidad
entonces el día siguiente me vuelvo para
francia
chicos está bien usted está en puesto
hubo arriba pero soy el dueño de mi
negocio soy el gerente general
jugo
y aunque
hagan como si fuera gerente general
les doy unos poderes y ustedes organizan
y el día siguiente me voy me voy de
viaje estamos en noviembre 2014 los
primeros días pasan estoy con mi familia
preocupado
pero pasado una semana no recibo
noticias pero ya una semana tampoco no
es tan grave dos semanas nada está un
poco
tres semanas oye acaba que está pasando
no recibo noticias
un mes llegamos a diciembre no tengo
noticias solamente datos que
intercambiamos en la nube pero los
números en la empresa no son el negocio
no representan lo que está pasando en la
vida de la empresa
no hay problema van a tener problemas
entre ellos se van a pelear con unos
clientes media tenemos problemas con
proveedores así que tranquilo y bien
noticia más
pero llegamos en diciembre primera
semana de diciembre segundo de semana y
nada
y seas consciente tienes casi 100
empleados no puedes dejar el negocio a
la deriva
sí puede ser pero mira las figuras en
organigrama
pues tu legitimidad para preguntar oye
dame
no me in zeiten un poco de la empresa no
no estoy
sí pero tienes tantos años trabajando en
esta empresa que así la tardía se hace
años atrás no puedes soltar al azar eso
lo lamento pero no estás en organigrama
un conflicto terrible
no no voy a acceder si yo decidió
confiar confío hasta el final es el
momento de mi vida en lo cual tengo que
ir hasta el final de mis condiciones
diciembre pasa nada pero si recibo un
mensaje
feliz año nuevo señor origen
a eso ha sido terrible
es el peor mensaje mensaje de los fines
de año que recibo
enero no recibo nada nada de nada
primera semana de febrero regresó a
limón
subo el segundo piso
y normalmente cuando entro es así
hola chicos como están ahora señor y ya
como están se levantan de su escritorio
nos abrazamos cuéntanos su viaje se
trata hoy el chico hacia hace 10 minutos
que estamos hablando ahora mano a la
obra o que hay que trabajar
pero esta vez no fue así
y esta vez
hola chicos cómo están
o la serie como esta
no puede ser
algo ha pasado
les invito uno por uno para saber qué
había pasado
vamos a tomar un café uno por uno y les
preguntó oye chicos
dime tú cómo
cómo les ha ido y cada uno me contaba
exactamente lo mismo pero con las mismas
emociones o sea
ellos habían resuelto problemas entre
ellos con clientes de la mejor forma
no no lo hubiera hecho mejor yo
que había pasado entre el 2003 y 2014
en el 2003 yo había
soltando responsabilidades o actividades
mientras en 2014 son ellos que han
elegido al jefe
más bien este jefe tampoco quiso ser
jefe pero ellos lo han nombrado para
alcanzar un propósito superior de la
empresa como es esencia hugo a no quiere
hacer jefe ser elegido por los demás y
cómo se sentían los demás haber elegido
a su jefe
pudieron juntos en inteligencia
colectiva
soltar su talento suelta sus energías
para llegar a las mejores soluciones
entonces que iba a hacer ahora
a una cosa muy importante muy importante
quien estuvo hugo es igual que ellos
este mismo no tiene cargo noche de
diplomas no tiene nada excepcional pero
hubo si tiene algo muy importante
hugo sabe escuchar jugo
hace lo que dice y tiene un gran poder
uo tiene el poder humilde de saber que
no sabe
y de tal forma que cuando toma
decisiones la toma de forma colectiva
decidí reinventarme
de inventarme porque tenía un paradigma
un pensamiento de empresario durante
años que decidí profundizar esta nueva
experiencia
entonces decidí pasar de jefe de
jardinero
porque el jardinero
me explico por si acaso
cuando un jardinero quiere que sus
plantas crezcan por si acaso jala las
hojas para que crezca la hoja la planta
varón
qué hace un jardinero un jardinero que
llega a las plantas la expone al sol le
pone un soporte la poda
es exactamente lo mismo que decidí hacer
con los ampliados crear las condiciones
para generar confianza para que puedan
autogestionarse para que puedan
equivocarse
es mejor dicho de otra manera es como
esta naranja en lugar de presionarla
para sacar el jugo y luego cambiarla no
mejor que exprimimos ligeramente para
extraer las pepas y la estepa son el
talento y las energías de cada uno para
que dé lo mejor de sí mismo y haciendo
de esta forma
sembramos pepas y cosechamos naranjos
es igual para una empresa
los resultados
han sido extraordinarios este proceso ha
iniciado hace cinco años y los dos
primeros años la productividad por
persona ha crecido de 29 por ciento la
rotación del personal disminuye el 50
por ciento
y la rentabilidad de la empresa nunca ha
sido tan elevado en 22 años
nuestras organizaciones son entes
orgánicos porque están compuestos por
personas
les invito a preguntarse lo siguiente
cuántas veces ustedes
se han atrevido a soltar el poder para
que las personas y las organizaciones
puedan crecer de forma orgánica
muchas gracias
[Aplausos]